yeah one of the things that's tough in
our situation as consultants and I
haven't talked to you about this but I
guess you'd agree is it's not
necessarily because a writer or a
director whoever we're working with is
consciously resisting or has that ego
it's that when they need to be listening
to us we're competing with about five
other voices going through their head
because when you're getting critique
like that you're thinking immediately I
did it wrong how can I make it better I
get it I get into that a lot with
writers I'll be working with them and
we'll be talking about the script and
they're jumping right to how do I fix it
how do I fix it and I'll say forget
fixing we're not fixing we're just we're
just talking about about the screenplay
and and trying to get them to relax
enough that those voices are not
drowning out whatever it is I'm saying
which usually isn't so much a critique
it is more just those questions and and
kind of leading them to their own
conclusions about what's working and not
working in their script working meaning
are they realizing the vision they had
to begin with for their story but that
it's tough to listen in that situation
even if you're not an egomaniac or
something it's just it's it's so ripe
for wanting to be defensive and also
cure whatever the problem is rather than
just taking it in and trusting that
we'll get there uh-huh yeah one thing
just to add to that the when you said
find out how do I fix it I run into that
a lot which is okay and I'll show them a
process or two or lead them to a
discovery and I can see their mind going
yeah but how come can we just get there
how can we just get there now I'm and
when I'm teaching people how to work
with actors okay but how can I just get
them to do what I want no and I think
that the frustrating thing for them is
to realize this is a process this is a
process that I have to go through
there's going to be a few
several steps like working with you on a
script like I don't just oh my Michaels
not just going to tell me right now how
to rewrite the scene that it's gonna be
fine and I'll write it down and then I'm
done no I have to go through and I have
to look at character and I have to look
at arcs and I have to I have to look at
a process and it's the same thing what
we're working with actors I have to look
at a process to get to the result so
there's a lot of this wanting a quick
fix or a quick technique or a quick
trick and the other thing you said about
the voices you had I was consulting on a
film that was eventually made by MGM and
I was working with the director and
we're working on the script and I was
help him see what's the potential is in
the script and the writer was there and
awareness could go and he kept going
this is great this is that's not what
the studio wants it's not what the
studio wants I said no no no forget what
the studio wants right now forget it
we're looking at a script we're looking
at a story we're looking at what's
potentially possible in this story but
he was so locked on and I don't even
know what he was thinking I don't know
what the studio had said to him but he
was so locked on that I'm sure they were
saying you know things like make it
funny
don't make it too dramatic and we're
probably looking at something more
dramatic you know and so suddenly a that
voice was just competing with everything
we were doing in the room it's kind of
like you said it as a director working
with actors as consultants I feel like
one of our main jobs is we've got to
create a safe space we've got to create
a safe space for the creative person you
have to create it for directors you're
working with I have to create it for
writers so they can trust okay wait I
get this now he's not going to tear me
apart it's not going to be about that at
all it's just were we're taking a
journey into what I wrote together and
see what together we can discover that I
might not have even realized was there
and see where we can go together with it
and it's not going to be about good or
bad right or wrong or I screwed up or I
did great it's just what's what's there
that we haven't discovered yet something
just occurred to me I don't hopefully
you agree with this I think you will
I can imagine going to an a consult
like not you or me but another
consultant for screenwriting or directed
and wanting tools techniques tricks
whatever that will work
you know formulas at work and I think
what Michael and I do even if it's just
one consultation and I say this because
you've consulted with me on a script I
wrote so I've had that experience but
and one it's not that actually what
happens and I think this is what happens
when I work with directors is we form a
relationship
we're not quick fix people we form a
relationship between consultant and
client and that in that relationship
which is a conversation we're guiding
them into a process into a way of
looking at not only that script or that
film I'm looking at I'm gonna help you
become a better director you're saying
I'm gonna help you come become a better
writer we'll work on this script right
now but it's it's the relationship with
the consultant which is actually in many
ways what all scripts are about anyway
is a relationship in others is we also
replicate this is how you work together
this is how two people communicate do
you know what I mean I don't sit here is
the teacher just tell you do this and
then you'll be fine I can show you
something but then I'm gonna help you
I'm gonna work with you to bring you to
the point that you can discover what I
already know or what I'm already talking
about so it's it's it's a it's a very
nurturing relationship it's not a
dictatorial or academic here's the
answer do it this way yeah I hope so
certainly because that's that's what
works I think
you